the Supreme Court rules in favor of
religious bakers Democrats struggle for
the House Majority and Bernie Sanders
makes the stupidest statements about
Disney ever I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show so much news I couldn't
even mention it all in the t's before
the show Bill Clinton also was on TV a
lot and we all remember now why Donald
Trump as president with Bill Clinton on
TV talking about where he stores his
cigars we have a lot to get to today
before we get to any of that I have a
few announcements so first of all we've
decided to honor father's day this year
with a special livestreams on Tuesday
June 12th at 7:00 p.m. Eastern
daily where God came Jeremy boring is
going to host a roundtable discussion
with me and Andrew Klavan and Michael
Nobles as well and we are going to sit
around and chat about all of the things
we'll discuss what fatherhood means and
my father's matter and how fatherhood
will stand up against an increasingly
anti male culture and subscribers will
be able to write in live questions for
us to answer on the air so you should
subscribe now so you can write those
live questions and then we'll care about
what you have to say again that's
Tuesday June 12th 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific and you can find our live stream
on Facebook and YouTube to watch so
don't miss it also more good news for
podcast listeners ben shapiro show along
with our other daily wired podcast is
now available on amazon alexa and the
google home device so now your home
could be filled with the rich supple
tones of my voice with the simple voice
command but first you have to activate
the show so the Lexile you have to
enable the skill it's like adding an app
you say Alexa enable the Ben Shapiro
shows skill and then you can tell her to
play or open Alexa play the Ben Shapiro
show and then Google doesn't need to be
added by user but you have to speak very
clearly for her to understand because I
don't know what Google's problem is but
just say a command like ok Google talk
to Ben Shapiro show or ok Google speak
to the Ben Shapiro show and now your
device should be able to play my podcast
and your quality of life will improve
the measurably if you need to review
those directions just go over to the pin
post on daily wired Twitter and daily
where Facebook to check it out ok now
that's not the only announcement also we
have to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Legal Zoom so it's time for that
mid-year check in it's almost halfway
through the year folks is crazy so if
you're like everyone else you have a few
things left on your to-do list for 2018
which is why Legal Zoom is extending
their friends and family discounts to
everyone right now which means for a
limited time you get 10% off the things
you keep putting on some of your small
business owner you need to make your
accountant happy by saving on your LLC
your DBA your S corp and more you can
also save money wrapping up your last
will or living trust
before you go on summer vacation in that
way if you're killed in a boating
accident then at least you took care of
that LegalZoom is not a law firm but
don't worry if legal questions are
holding you up their network of
independent attorneys can provide advice
for your business your estate plan and
so get the things you need to get done
at legalzoom.com right now and save 10%
with legal zooms friends and family
discount just be sure to enter promo
code ben and get that friends and family
discount in the referral box to check
out this offer is only available for a
limited time go over to Legal Zoom calm
right now I've been using Legal Zoom for
years and now again they have this
entire new service where if you have
legal questions you can go to a network
of independent Ernies who can give you
advice for your business estate plan etc
use promo code Ben and Legal Zoom calm
and you get 10% off Legal Zoom or life
meets legal check out Legal Zoom calm
and use that promo code Ben all right so
just breaking before today's show the
big news was that the Supreme Court has
ruled in the masterpiece at cake shop
case so if you don't remember the
masterpiece cake shop case this is the
case where a guy owned a bakery and
these this gay couple came in in 2012
and they wanted a cake for their
same-sex wedding and he said no i'm a
religious baker so no and he'd be happy
to sell them a cake if they were just
gay people who want a cake he'd be happy
to give them their cake because who
cares but they wanted a cake that set on
it you know a happy wedding to Bob and
Joe or whatever it was and this
Christian Baker said listen I'm not
gonna be part of fording what I think is
a sin which seems like a basic American
freedom
well the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission immediately cracked down on
the guy and tried to basically run him
out of business for this grave and
horrible sin we've seen the same sort of
issue arise with bear enough Stutzman up
in the state of Oregon where paranal
Stutzman was in Washington Washington
bearing all Stutzman we're apparent all
Stutzman was florists and she didn't
want to do floral arrangements for a
lesbian wedding and then she was
basically run out of business by the
state we've seen the same thing with
photographers in New Mexico so we've
seen this sort of thing happening all
over the country so the Supreme Court
avoided the big issue so the headline
that you're hearing today from the left
is oh my god the Supreme Court has stood
with religious people against gay people
that's what the Supreme Court just it
okay first of all here's my view of this
case and every other case like it I do
not believe that it is the government's
job to tell you who you can and cannot
do business with and that includes
discrimination
okay I'm open about this I think that if
you want to discriminate against a Jew
that is your problem and you know what I
will do I will go start an alternative
business and I will run you out of
business I will go through the business
across the street and they will get my
patronage and they will run you out of
business I think this is true across the
board I don't see why this is a freedom
of religion issue per se because it
seems like a freedom of association
to me now I understand is unpalatable to
people because we have this weird idea
in America that if you don't like
something it ought to be illegal well I
don't like a lot of things I don't think
they ought to be illegal I'm not a
same-sex marriage fan I don't think it
ought to be illegal
I'm libertarian on same-sex marriage I
think the government should get
completely out of the business of
marriage well just as I and libertarian
on the issue of same-sex marriage
I'm libertarian on the issue of whether
a business owner ought to be forced to
cater to a particular population even if
that business owner is a jerk even if
that business owner is a racist or a
homophobe well you want to be a racist
or homophobic s what your even go out of
business because that's the way the
market works capitalism is the single
greatest force for tolerance in the
history of humanity not government
control from above okay so that's my
perspective on this but this case
doesn't go that far it also doesn't go
as far as to even say that religious
people have a right to act religiously
in their business the case doesn't even
say that if you are a baker that you
have the right to reject catering to a
same-sex wedding instead this case has
decided seven to two on the narrowest
possible grounds and that is the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission is mean
really that's how the case was decided
the case is written by Anthony Kennedy
who was an execrable justice just an
awful awful justice he has never seen a
copy of the Constitution apparently and
so he just sort of wanders around in his
bathrobe and depending on whether he had
his Metamucil led bowel movement that
morning he decides how to rule so here
is his ruling today delivering the
opinion of the court and there's a
nonsensical ruling it's a nonsensical
ruling because it doesn't get to any key
issue it's good for the particular Baker
in this case but it does not establish a
broad principle that religious people
can actually act religiously in their
businesses which you would assume would
be protected by freedom of religion I
mean when I say freedom of religion
generally what I mean is my ability to
act religiously throughout my life
including in my business that's not what
the Supreme Court says instead they
simply evade the issue so the the court
holds and this is in the courts summary
this is the summary of the case at the
very beginning of every case the court
puts out basically a summary of the
ruling here's what they hold the laws
and the Constitution can and in some
instances must protect gay persons and
gay couples in the exercise of their
civil rights but religious and
philosophical objections to gay marriage
are protected views and in some
instances protected forms of expression
which is extraordinarily vague well it
is unexceptionable that Colorado law can
protect gay persons in acquiring
products and services on the same terms
and conditions as are offered to other
members of the public who all must be
applied
a manner that is neutral toward religion
and now you ask how is that possible how
is it possible that you're gonna be
neutral toward religion and crack down
on religion while protecting same-sex
couples how are you going to do exactly
that well they don't answer that
question instead they just say that in
this particular case the Colorado Civil
Rights Commission was means a religious
people they said mean things about
religious people and that means that we
can't uphold their decision in this case
the the guy in this kitchen in Jack
Phillips healings masterpiece cake shop
his claim that using his artistic skills
to make an expressive statement a
wedding endorsement in his own voice and
of his own creation has a significant
First Amendment speech component and
implicates his deep insincere religious
beliefs his dilemma was understandable
in 2012 this in this line his dilemma
was understandable in 2012 which was
before Colorado recognized the validity
of gay marriages performed in the state
or before this Court issued its decision
in ubers fell even the state's position
at the time there are some force to
Philips argument that he was not
unreasonable in deeming his decision
lawful state law at the time also
afforded shopkeepers some latitude to
decline to create specific messages they
considered offensive indeed while the
instant enforcement proceedings were
pending the state Civil Rights Division
concluded in at least three cases that a
Baker acted lawfully in declining to
create cakes with decorations that's
mean gay persons or gay marriages
Philips too is entitled to a neutral and
respectful consideration of his claims
in all circumstances of the case so
let's stop there for a second what they
are saying is that Jack Phillips now
he'd be crazy basically to say that he
won't serve a same-sex marriage but back
in 2012 when it was still illegal for
same-sex people to marry in many places
across the country for people of the
same sex to marry each other in many
places across the country back then it
was understandable that he was stupid
but now if he tried it now I mean come
on it's the law of the land so you can
see the Supreme Court leaving the door
open to not protecting the rights of
somebody who in 2016 says I don't wish
to participate in the same-sex marriage
instead they're saying well way back
then it was different right back then
Obama supported traditional marriage but
now everything's changed so obviously if
somebody tried to do the exact same
thing now and now of course it would be
unconstitutional and then the case can
sit the court continues that
consideration was compromised by the
Commission's treatment of Phillips this
case what they're saying is that the
Civil Rights Commission should have been
nice to Phillips they were mean to
Phillips and therefore that a decision
is not okay their consideration was
compromised by the Commission's
treatment which showed elements of a
clear and impermissible hostility toward
the sincere religious beliefs motivating
his objection as the record show
some of the commissioners at this
Commission's formal public hearings
endorsed the view that religious beliefs
can not legitimately be carried into the
public sphere of commercial domain
disparage Phillips faces despicable and
characterized it as merely rhetorical
and compared his invocation of his
sincerely held religious beliefs to
defenses of slavery on the Holocaust no
commissioners objected to the comments
nor were they mentioned in the later
State Court ruling or just about in the
briefs filed here the comments must cast
doubt on the fairness and impartiality
of the Commission's adjudication of
Phillips's case okay again none of the
tested with anything so what they are
saying is that the Commission said mean
things about Phillips and his religious
practice the reality however is that
that should have nothing to do with
whether or not Phillips's behavior is
constitutional this should be a very
easy decision people misinterpret what
freedom of religion is supposed to be
about so the court has come up with all
of these cases where they say a freedom
of religion provides you a special
freedom a special freedom and that
special freedom is designed in order to
allow you to provide your sincerely held
religious beliefs in public but how do
you decide what is sincerely held as
opposed to non sincerely held and if you
held a sincere religious beliefs they
should hold slaves obviously the court
wouldn't be okay with that so it's not
sincere religious beliefs instead
there's a three-prong religion test
that's laid forth in a case called Lemon
all of this is stupid
okay the reality is that what the
founders believed is laid out very
clearly in the first amendments of the
Constitution it is laid out in two sides
of the same coin
the Free Exercise Clause and the
Establishment Clause so the Free
Exercise Clause the First Amendment says
that the free exercise of religion shall
not be abridged and then it says that
there shall be no establishment of
religion okay these are the same Clause
people read them separately so they say
that Establishment Clause about the
government can't put In God We Trust on
coins or some such nonsense and freedom
of religion is can you smoke peyote in
violation of federal drug law on native
resinated reservation that was an actual
case back in the early 90s Employment
Division versus Smith I believe it's
called but one of the problems with this
reading of the First Amendment is that
the whole point of the First Amendment
is to protect you from the government
becoming large and overbearing and
encroaching so what it's saying is you
should not have a government that
establishes a religion because that will
burden other people's free exercise of
religion in other words the smaller the
government is the less it's going to run
into particular freedoms and this is
true across the board it's true a
freedom of association it's for a
freedom of speech
the smaller the government is
the less it is going to burden anybody's
particular exercise of a freedom that
they hold so your freedom of religion is
not going to be burdened so long as the
government's not getting up in your
grill but now the government's up in
your grill with anti-discrimination law
particularly in this case and so they
have decided that anti-discrimination
law runs up against religious liberty
concerns okay in reality
anti-discrimination law for private
businesses to me is a serious
constitutional problem I understand why
people did it I sympathize with the
feelings for it I understand that it was
an attempt to wipe out discrimination in
the private sector I don't think it
accomplished that in in quite the way
people think it did the reality is that
in order to overcome the marketplace
which does not discriminate the
marketplace hates discrimination in
order to overcome the marketplace the
government had to implement rules
discriminating in the first place now I
have a whole video you can view it on
YouTube about why it is that
anti-discrimination laws are
significantly less important than
capitalism is in removing barriers to
people getting the sort of care and
service that they want and I point out
that Jim Crow was not put in place by
private people Jim Crow was put in place
by the government was the government
literally establishing laws that
prevented people from serving people in
their restaurants there were actual laws
in the south and places like Alabama
that if you owned a restaurant you had
to have a separate seating section for
black people and if you violated that
the government would come in and sue you
for that the government would come in
and find you or jail you for that
because if it hadn't been for that law
then people would have just opened up
the restaurants which is exactly what
happened in the early 1960s with for
example the Woolworth counter
demonstration in mmm try remember which
city it was in the early 1960s before
the Civil Rights Act a black people
walked into Woolworths they said we're
not leaving and then Woolworths
integrated hey that's because the market
works the market does work okay the
reason that I keep saying the market
works is because the market doesn't make
impositions on anybody the government
does again in just a second I'm gonna
continue with the analysis of this new
case which again everybody is over
reading and actually I don't think boats
all that well for religious freedom in
the United States but first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at blue
apron so blue apron as you know is the
best home delivery kit that you can get
when it comes to cooking meals they're
teaming up now with best-selling
cookbook author and Chrissy Teigen and
they're bringing you some of her
favorite recipes to make at home so get
ready for six weeks of awesome flavorful
cooking again what they do is they send
you all the ingredients they send you
all
the recipes and then you you're at home
with your kids and you make the meal
it's great I love cooking with my two
kids
you'll love doing it too and they make
it super easy with chrissy teigen x'
menu this this week I guess and they
have hot they have garlic and soy glazed
shrimp with charred broccoli and hot
green pepper sauce sesame chicken
noodles with bok choy and again you
don't have to set foot in the grocery
they've convenience and variety they
deliver fresh pre-portion ingredients
and step-by-step recipes directly
towards where everything can be cooked
in under 45 minutes and the menu changes
every week depending on what's in season
they offer twelve new recipes every week
customers can pick two three or four
recipes based on what best fits your
schedule and they send only high-quality
products okay everything from blue apron
I've heard from people in the office
people in the office use blue apron they
say it's just terrific and right now you
can check out this week's menu and get
your first three meals for free at blue
apron comm slash Shapiro that's blue
apron comm slash Shapiro to get your
first three meals for free blue apron
comm slash appear a blue apron is indeed
a better way to cook and again the meals
are done making these a restaurant
quality gourmet meals that you will be
making yourself I mean I'm looking at
pictures that look amazing so check it
out blue apron calm slash Shapiro and
you get your first three meals for free
okay so back to the analysis of the
Supreme Court's decision in the
masterpiece cake shop case so they
continue this again the summary of the
case they say the consideration was
compromised by the Commission's
treatment of Phillips's case which
showed elements of a clear and
impermissible hostility toward his
sincere religious beliefs so they're not
saying that religious people get to
actually act out their religion in
public or that freedom of religion
really exists they're just saying you're
not allowed to be mean to religious
people then they say another indication
of hostility is the different treatment
of Phillips's case and the cases of
other Baker's with objections to
anti-gay messages who prevail before the
Commission the Commission ruled against
Phillips in part on the theory that any
message not on the requested cake would
be a truth on the requested cake rather
would be attributed to the customer not
to the Baker
if the division did not address this
point in any of the cases involving the
requests for cakes depicting anti-gay
marriage symbolism so then the case
continues for these reasons the
Commission's treatment of Phillips's
case violated the state's duty under the
First Amendment not to base laws or
regulation on hostility to a religion or
religious viewpoint the government
consistent with the Constitution's
guarantee of free exercise cannot impose
regulations that are hostile to the
religious beliefs of affected citizens
and cannot act in a manner that passes
judgment upon or presupposes the
illegitimate II of religious beliefs and
practices and then
they say the inference here is thus that
real Philips religious objection was not
considered with the neutrality required
by the Free Exercise Clause the state's
interest could have been weighed against
Philips sincere religious objections in
a way consistent with the requisite
religious neutrality that must be
strictly observed but the officials
expressions of hostility to religion and
some of the commissioners comments were
inconsistent with that requirements okay
there's a dumb decision it's a dumb
decision again where they're coming down
is that if they had been nice about it
they could have rejected this guy's
religious views nothing in the
Constitution says you can be nice about
it and still get rid of people's
religious views there's no provision of
the First Amendment that says free
exercise of religion must be protected
except when people are really nice to
you if they're really nice about about
removing your religious exercise clauses
well then we can get rid of them nothing
in the Constitution says all this and
that's exactly of course what is said in
some of the dissents by members of the
Supreme Court who are on the right so
Clarence Thomas writes again he always
writes very good sense I really enjoy
Clarence Thomas's writing because I
agree that the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission violated Jack Phillips his
right to freely exercise his religion as
justice gore said she also wrote a
dissent explains our concurrence rather
the Commission treated Phillips's case
differently from a similar case
involving three other Baker's while
Phillips rightly prevails on his free
exercise claim I write separately to
address his free speech claim the court
does not address this claim because it
has some uncertainties about the record
and then he concludes that even after
describing his conduct this way the
Court of Appeals concluded Phillips his
conduct was not expressive it was not
protected speech and reason that an
outside observer would think Phillips
was merely complying with Colorado's
public accommodations law not expressing
a message this reasoning flouts bedrock
principles of our free speech
jurisprudence and would justify
virtually any law that compels
individuals to speak it should not pass
without comment so in just second I'm
gonna go through Clarence Thomas's
entire opinion continue going through
his entire opinion so here's what he
says he says the First Amendment
applicable to the States through the
Fourteenth Amendment prohibits state
laws that abridge the freedom of speech
when interpreting this command the court
has distinguished between regulations of
speech and regulations of conduct the
latter generally do not abridge the
freedom of speech even if they impose
incidental burdens on expression as the
court explains today public
accommodations while usually regulate
conduct as a general matter public
accommodations law do not target speech
but instead prohibit the act of
discriminating against individuals in
the provision of public
available goods so the court makes this
distinction I think this distinction is
stupid by the way I think the
distinction between free free speech and
and free exercise of public
accommodations for example is overstated
so in other words I think it is an
aspect if the ten aspects of speech to
burn a flag I don't see why it's not an
aspect of speech to say I don't want to
care for this person in my establishment
it may be speech you don't like it may
be speech if it's gross may be feature I
don't like but I failed to see how the
First Amendment doesn't protect that
freedom of association or that freedom
of speech in any case Thomas does
respect that distinction he says
although public accommodations laws
generally regulate conduct particulars
of them can burden protected speech when
a public accommodations law has the
effect of declaring speech itself to be
a public accommodation the First
Amendment applies with full force and
then he goes on to describe all of the
ways that this is a burden on free
speech for this masterpiece cake shop
owner says the conduct that the Colorado
Court of Appeals described to Phillips
creating and designing custom wedding
cakes is expressive Phillips considers
himself an artist the logo for
masterpiece cake shop is an artist paint
palette with a paintbrush in a baker's
whisk behind the counselor Phillips has
a picture that depicts him as an artist
painting on a canvas Phillips takes
exceptional care with each cake that he
creates sketching the design out on
paper choosing the color scheme creating
the frosting and decorations baking and
sculpting the cake decorating it
delivering it to the wedding
here's why I think that Thomas is
dissent here or concurrence is actually
not wide enough the same can be said of
any hotelier so you own a
bed-and-breakfast people one button
breakfast are very careful about how
they make their button breakfast right
they're very careful about how they do
the decor they're very careful about the
kind of accommodations they provide
they're very careful about the kind of
food that they cook to separate artistry
from business seems to me a little bit
of a false distinction that people are
making when it comes to First Amendment
issues in any case Thomas concludes by
essentially arguing that this is a
violation of the First Amendment the
Colorado Court of Appeals is wrong to
conclude that Phillips's conduct was not
expressive because a reasonable observer
would think he's merely complying with
Colorado's public accommodations law
this argument would justify any law that
compelled protected speech and this
Court has never accepted it from the
beginning this courts compelled speech
precedents have rejected arguments that
resolve every issue of power in favor of
those in authority so obviously I agree
with Justice Thomas here even though I
think he's making distinctions that I
find unjustified in Prior law men of
they're the leftist justice you have
Ginsburg who dissented and justice
Sotomayor to something and they say
basically that the religion doesn't
matter free exercise doesn't matter the
government should be able to tell you to
do whatever the government wants to tell
you to do justice Gorsuch wrote a very
good concurrence in which justice
Gorsuch makes the case that and he joins
with Justice Alito in his concurrence in
which they basically say that this does
violate freedom of religion they say an
Employment Division Department of Human
Resources of Oregon versus Smith this
Court held that a neutral in generally
applicable law will usually survive a
constitutional free exercise challenge
but we now know with certainty when the
government fails to act neutrally toward
the free exercise of religion it tends
to run into trouble
today's decision respect these
principles as the court explains the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission failed
to act neutrally toward Jack Phillips
his religious faith may be most notably
the Commission allowed three other
Baker's to refuse a customer's request
that would have required them to violate
their secular commitments he says the
only wrinkle is this in the face of so
much evidence suggesting hostility
toward mr. Phillips's sincerely held
religious beliefs two of our colleagues
have written separately to suggest that
the Commission acted neutrally towards
faith when it treated him differently
from the other Baker's or that it could
have easily done so consistent with the
First Amendment but respectfully I do
not see how we might rescue the
Commission from its error a full view of
the head of the facts helps point the
way to the problem start with William
Jack's case he approached three Baker's
and asked them to prepare cakes with
messages disapproving same-sex marriages
on religious grounds
all three Baker's refused mr. Jack's
request stating they found his requests
offensive to their secular convictions
mr. Jack responded by filing complaints
with the Colorado Civil Rights Division
he pointed to discrimination against you
point he pointed the Colorado
anti-discrimination Act which prohibits
discrimination against customers in
public accommodations because of
religious creed sexual orientation or
certain other traits and then mr. Jack
was given the go-ahead and then he
compares that Gorsuch does to the case
with regard to to the Phillips he says
the facts show these two cases share all
legally salient features in both cases
the effect on the customer was the same
Baker's refused service to persons who
bore a statutory statutorily protected
trait religious faith or sexual
orientation but in both cases the
Baker's refused service intending only
to honor a personal conviction and
here's his point his point is you can't
treat these two things disparately just
because you change the language so of
course justice course edge is right
about all of this also okay now in just
a second I want to get to the fact that
Democrats extry
issues related to everything from this
case to just general politics are
putting them behind the eight-ball when
it comes to elections but first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
stamps.com
so these days you can get practically
anything on demand you can listen to my
podcast on demand come over to YouTube
and you can watch the video I just did
with Joe Rogan on demand you'll really
enjoy it but why are you still going
over to the post office to mail letters
and packages when you can get postage on
demand with stamps calm no matter how
much you like the post office it's a lot
easier if you're sitting in your office
just to print out the postage and not
have to run there and spend the time in
the car or in line with Sam's comm you
can access all the great services of the
post office directly from your desk 24/7
when it is convenient for you buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package using your own computer and
printer
the mail carrier picks it up just click
print mail you're done it could not be
any easier we use stamps calm here at
the office to save ourselves time money
I use it in my home as well right now
use Shapiro and you get a special offer
it includes up to 55 bucks a free
postage that's pretty solid plus a
digital scale and a four week trial you
just sit there and you've weighed the
mail and tells you how much you need to
spend and then you buy the postage and
then you print it right down on the
envelope or onto a sticker or on a piece
of paper you tape it to the envelope
you're ready to go go - stamps calm
before you do anything else click on the
radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro again that
stamps calm and you use promo code
Shapiro includes up to 55 bucks of free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial go check it out it's totally worth
it stamps calm and use promo code
Shapiro okay so bad news for the
Democrats first of all the Supreme Court
decision that came out earlier today
that basically suggests that Democrats
have overstepped their boundaries it
does go to the attitude many Democrats
have toward public policy so this
decision was essentially decided on the
basis of the meanness of the Colorado
Civil Rights Commission them being mean
to religious people
well Democrats still don't get this they
still don't get that the more nasty and
vial they are and the worse their policy
is the less people are interested in
working with them under under most
circumstances so there's a poll out
today that shows that Democrats are
basically in a dead heat with
Republicans for taking back the house
according to CBS News YouGov
battleground tracker
how many districts the Democrats forget
how many Republicans would get as of
today the 2018 looks like a toss-up for
control at the moment
Democrats would most likely need wood it
would most likely get 219 seats of the
election were held today
which is only one more than the 218
needed for majority and the Republicans
216 the margin of error on this model is
nine seats so control is totally up for
grabs if you would have told me six
months ago that Donald Trump would be
the President of the United States would
be riding in the low 40s and the
approval ratings and that Democrats
would not be able to retake the house I
wouldn't thought you were insane but
this is how bad Democrats are at
everything and maybe the reason
Democrats are bad at everything is
because they're both nasty and they have
bad policy hey Bernie Sanders is the
most obvious case of this so Bernie
Sanders who's become the ideological
thought leader of the Democratic Party
which is an incredible thing for a man
who loves putting this much to become
the ideological thought leader of the
Democratic Party it says that we live in
a new era an era in which everybody
appreciates putting a lot but Bernie
Sanders over the weekend he was
campaigning in Orange County
why is he an Orange County isn't he from
Vermont you asked why yes but Bernie
doesn't know where he is so what the
hell he gives the same speech in Orange
County
he doesn't in Vermont in any case he he
goes to Orange County and he is stumping
for $15 minimum wage in Orange County
and he's particularly directing his ire
at Disneyland now when you strike at
Disneyland you strike near my soul hey
Disneyland is wonderful place how dare
you sir
Disneyland is one of the best run places
in all of America if thirty thousand
employees that are the single largest
employer in Orange County
Disneyland also hilarious no matter how
much social justice warrior ring you do
you are not immune from the evils of
envy and the anger of Bernie Sanders
so Disneyland is a very left place right
Disneyland has their there Gay Pride
days and they have everything over at
Disneyland that fosters the these sort
of left-leaning politics of Disney as a
company doesn't matter Bernie Sanders
wants to come after you Disney but
Bernie Sanders will come after you
he's pushing $15 minimum wage in Orange
County and here's Bernie Sanders railing
on Disneyland because Disneyland does
not sound proper pudding instead they
only have those churros and it hurts my
teeth because my dentures cannot chew
through the churros but if they would
stop putting everything would be much
better here's Bernie Sanders in Orange
County go
[Applause]
I want to hear the moral defense were to
church now I want to hear the moral
defence of a company that makes nine
billion in profits four hundred million
for the CEOs at happy thirty year work
going hungry I'm hungry also okay so um
he would he like to hear a formal
defense could I have one I mean if he
wants to hear one or moral defense
here's my moral defense Disney hires two
hundred thousand people across the
United States two hundred thousand
people across the United States Bernie
Sanders once worked in a Vermont commune
they could not even keep him employed
seriously the story is that he was so
lazy he would sit around talking
politics all day and he wouldn't go out
like work the earth or something and the
Vermont com unite to get rid of him so
here's the defense of Disney okay number
one Disney as the largest employer in
Orange County one of the reasons they
have such a good profit margin is
because they actually treat their
workers pretty well people want to work
at Disney this is a simple supply and
demand and supply okay this is simple
supply demand curve bottom line is there
are lots of people want to work at
Disney many people cannot work at Disney
that means that there is a higher supply
than there is a demand
this means that Disney cannot pay all
these people tons and tons of money but
that said Disney is actually a pretty
good employer doesn't care to the facts
okay Disney has been in negotiations
with unions like the Masters Services
Council which represents nearly 10,000
cast members and Disney has already
offered a plan that would get to $15
minimum wage by 2020 the state of
California which is endorse $15 minimum
wage it won't arrive until 2022 so
Disney has already offered a deal now
gets a $15 minimum wage by 2020 Disney
has also increased the number of their
employees by 50% over the last decade
maybe that might have to do with their
hiring practices and if they don't pay
people exorbitant fees for dressing up
in Chippendale costumes and running
around the park and they're not paying
people eight hundred dollars an hour to
dress up as Chippendale okay hourly cast
members already receive overtime in
premiums nearly nine in ten leadership
workers and operations started off as
hourly employees because it turns out
minimum wage jobs are designed to move
you beyond the minimum wage jobs okay
and in 2017
more than 2,000 part-time workers like
20 to 22 hundred part-time workers
became
I'm furthermore Disneyland Resort pays
an average of thirteen thousand five
hundred dollars per family for full-time
workers medical premiums now one of the
things is very weird said aunt Bernie
Sanders's all it's just unaffordable
what's his knees doing look at what
they're doing it's just so terrible
Sanders doesn't ever look at his home
state like is he ever in Vermont Bernie
Sanders does he ever spend any time in
Vermont because if he looked at his home
state he might notice that according to
an out of reach report from the National
Law income housing coalition Vermonters
have to work 1.7 full time minimum-wage
jobs to afford a one-bedroom rental home
so minimum wage won't pay for a
one-bedroom rental home in Vermont
Vermont has the fifth highest shortfall
between average renter wage and tuba and
two-bedroom housing wage by the way the
other four that are ahead of them
California clocks and third why Maryland
in New Jersey notice anything about
those five states notice anything about
those five states I just mentioned all
blue all deep blue states which have a
massive shortfall between average renter
wage and two-bedroom housing wage
shocking shocking why is it that a state
like California it has boosted its
minimum wage supremely progressive why
is it no one can afford rent
well because it's governed by Democrats
and as I will explain in a minute it
turns out Democratic policy across the
board is hot garbage on this sort of
stuff so now Bernie Sanders wants to do
for Orange County what Democrats did for
Seattle go after Amazon Starbucks
Microsoft raise the minimum wage drive
business out that's exactly what's
happened in Seattle by the way according
to a University of Washington study
quote employees increased wages which
you'd expect even mandated law but they
also cut hours and they cut jobs it's in
just a second I'm gonna talk about
California the state that Bernie Sanders
is targeting right now is a great
article by Michael Shellenberger over at
Forbes I want to talk about but first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at man crate so Father's Day is coming
up now is your time show your dad that
you care about your that don't just send
him a text message don't just get him a
beer man happy Father's Day don't be a
lazy bum okay go out to mine crates and
get your dad a man crate because these
are hand-picked and prepackaged gifts
for every type of dad they've got the
knife making kit for hands-on dads
they've got the whiskey appreciation kit
for fathers who like the finer things
and also can't stand to deal with you so
they just want to go over in the corner
and get drunk the whiskey appreciation
crate most gifts are sealed and it
wouldn't crate with a crowbar right
that's why it's called man crates
because you can actually pry it open if
your dad's really buffing yours
with hands but reality is gonna need the
crowbar you've got the engraved crowbar
II prize that sucker open it's awesome
we have over here an ammo can filled
with poker chips and once I get friends
I promise you it's gonna be awesome I'm
gonna play with those poker chips from
man crates it's just gonna be great with
man crates you're giving to add more
than a gift you're giving them a gift
experience unlike any other Plus every
man crate comes with a 100% satisfaction
guarantee right now get your special
Father's Day discount today at man
crates calm slash Ben it's a limited
time offer again only for Father's Day
so you got to do it right now men crates
calm slash pen go and check it out not
only because I love saying mine and
crates but also because the gifts are
awesome and you'll really enjoy them
more importantly saw your dad so check
it out man crates dot-com slash Ben all
right so I want to discuss how
California is failing Islanders Bill
Clinton we solvent got into Bill Clinton
I want to discuss Melania missing who
we're gonna discuss all of those things
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daley wire comm and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of this
show live you get to be part of our
mailbag you get the rest of the Andrew
Clavin show live there are some Michael
Noel's show live also when you subscribe
it means that you are automatically up
alerted to our our interviews like the
limits of the Joe Rogan so check that
out as well if you want to get the
annual subscription you get this the
very greatest and all beverage vessels
look at this the leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr you can look the power is
just infuse into me all I do is pick it
up and boom my energy levels twice as
high so if you're playing it on twice
speed after this you have to reduce it
to one and a half or one speed just the
way it works okay to check it out $99 a
year you get this the leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr and please go over and
subscribe again over at Google Play
stitcher Apple iTunes whatever whatever
app you are using subscribe and please
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so while Bernie Sanders is standing
around complaining about minimum wage in
Orange County is worth noting that
California is a is a hellhole ok
and I say that advisedly I've lived my
entire life in California it is headed
precisely the wrong direction so there's
a great piece by Michael Shellenberger
over at Forbes calm talking about what
has happened here so what he basically
suggests is that it's a real life
Elysium
he says homeless encampments of hundreds
of people have cropped up around the
state in the last two years occasionally
they are rapid ravaged by hepatitis A
which killed 20 people last year in
Silicon Valley 132 people died on the
street in 2016 up from 85 and 2015 in
San Diego 117 people died on the streets
up from 56 and in last year San Diego
city workers nearly killed a homeless
person after accidentally throwing her
and attention was sleeping in into the
back of a garbage truck so well done
everybody in California meanwhile you
can buy a really expensive house in
California I know I have one it is true
that workers in California are an 11%
more than counterparts nationally but
that's not enough to make up for
mortgage payments and rents that are 44%
and 37% higher respectively than the
national average 56 percent of
Californians could afford a middle-class
home in 2012 in the third quarter of
2017 just 28 percent could okay this is
the way that people escape poverty is by
buying a home in the United States
largely for about 40 years from 1930 to
1970 black families were channeled into
renting rooms and denied loans whereas
white families were encouraged to buy
homes richard Rothstein explains it was
that it was that primary discrimination
that kept african-americans out of white
suburbs and then affordability so once
the prices rose black families couldn't
even buy into a lot of these areas
environmentalism is used to the staff
I'd de facto racial segregation in
California housing as well environmental
lawsuits are a major reason for longer
delays and higher costs of new housing
last September Governor Jerry Brown
signed housing legislation that will
raise 250 million dollars per year to
subsidize housing but that's just enough
to subsidize about a little under 2,000
units annually at a time when a hundred
to two hundred thousand annual units are
needed so it's all of this left policy
all these people who are saying that
California is too progressive I mean
that it's too right-wing and that's why
you have problems like Orange County no
it's the California is too progressive
and that's why you have problems like
the problems in Orange County it's just
foolish
all the way through and it's no shock
progressive policy everywhere when taken
to its extreme fails California is no
exception
to all of this this is why you're seeing
a massive drain in Venezuela's funny I
was walking from New York last week as
you saw it we talked about last week I
met with nikki Haley she was walking
down embassy Road there and I walked
past the Venezuelan embassy and I said
to daily water God King Jeremy boring I
said to him inside that building is the
luckiest person in Venezuela because
that person is not in Venezuela that
person is in New York right eating good
food and not dog there's a reason that
all of these socialist countries are
failing it's a reason that California is
failing as well okay so meanwhile let's
talk a little bit about Bill Clinton so
Bill Clinton is back in the news for all
people on the Left who can't understand
why so many people on the right don't
care about the moral the moral silliness
and moral evils of President Trump let's
travel back just 20 years 20 short ears
to when Bill Clinton was president of
the United States and stooping his
interns with cigars let's just recall
that and then let's recall that Bill
Clinton's wife ran for election in 2016
and that Bill Clinton have been the
First Lady of the United States if
Hillary Clinton had won okay maybe you
can start to imagine why it is that
maybe our standards have dropped off a
little bit for presidents of the United
States so Bill Clinton is back on the
back on the press trail that's because
he's now co-written a book with James
Patterson meaning neither one of them
wrote it but they both stuck their name
on it and Bill Clinton was talking about
the presidency and it got real awkward
because he was asked specifically about
Monica Lewinsky and crying about Monica
Lewinsky this is an apologizing to
Monica Lewinsky this is a clip 16 did
you ever apologize no yes and nobody
believes that I got out of that for free
I left the White House sixteen million
dollars in debt but you typically have
ignored gaping facts in describing this
and I bet you don't even know them okay
so he's dead but he's dead Brookline so
he gone with the dead broke and then he
was asked specifically about apologizing
to Monica Lewinsky and and he said that
he has not apologized him that he has
apologized to Monica Lewinsky because he
apologized to everyone then he went into
Bill Clinton lecture mode right he's got
his bony finger and sort of wagging at
people yeah I can't imagine why people
this is my favorite part he says that he
couldn't be elected today Bill Clinton
he says that no I couldn't
today I couldn't win today because I'm
too nice I'm too kind here's what he had
to say I don't like all this I couldn't
be elected anything now because I just
don't like embarrassing people my mother
would have whipped me for five days in a
row when I was a little boy if I spent
all my time bad-mouthing people like
this okay you literally had your
campaign go out and say that if you drag
a 20 through a trailer park a bunch of
women would follow it okay in defense of
your behavior with kathleen willey and
your defensive with with paula jones and
monica lewinsky and jennifer flowers
okay bill clinton Shuman okay he is a
garbage human the fact that Bill Clinton
is so widely beloved is because he is
exactly the same as Trump in the sense
that everybody knows that he's a grifter
every no secret or he's an honest
grifter he's honest about his grifting
everybody knew that he was grifting for
years and he still continues to grift I
just love that he's now going to be the
moral voice of the Democratic Party yeah
good luck with it I love the James
Patterson is sitting there like I can't
believe this hey James Patterson's just
sitting there right next to him like I
can't believe I have to be here for this
interview this is so awkward this is so
terrible and so awkward and then Bill
Clinton said you know if this were a
Democrat in office we'd be impeaching
that Democrat already I think if roles
were reversed now this is me just
talking about it based on my experience
if there were a Democratic president and
these facts were presidents most people
I know I'm watching tintin hearings
would have begun already okay that's
that's probably true because Republicans
run the Congress but if Democrats around
the Congress and Pietschmann hearings
would not have begun already because
Democrats voted not to impeach President
Clinton who openly lied he perjured
himself and he lied to the American
people and nobody seemed to care so if
you're wondering look there's a big gap
I've talked about this before is a big
gap between Republicans over the age of
60 and Republicans under the age of 40
Republicans under the age of 40 when
they look at President Trump they see a
guy who fibs a lot who's dishonest who
is behaved egregiously in his personal
life
and they don't like any of that
Republicans over the age of 60 they
remember Bill Clinton they remember this
guy and they say well I'm not gonna be
lectured on morality by the same people
who ran around telling me that Bill
Clinton was a defensible guy that Bill
Clinton was a wonderful human being and
that anyone who criticized Bill Clinton
was doing so only because of their print
interest in sex this is a real gap in
knowledge base between people who are
under 40 and people who are over 60 in
the Republican Party I'm not saying
people who are under 40 are wrong
President Trump I am saying that when
Democrats say why are Republicans so
much in Trump's camp it's because
they're not gonna take lecture seriously
from people who pretend that JFK and
Bill Clinton were standard bearers for
morality and values in virtue because
that's just silly
it's just silly okay now speaking of
President Trump we do have to get to
president Trump's comments over the
weekend so President Trump went on
Twitter as he is so apt to do and he
decided that would be worthwhile
tweeting a bunch of things about the
Russia investigation by the way it is
never worthwhile tweeting a bunch of
things about the Russia investigation
President Trump has done a good job of
undermining sort of the credibility of
that investigation but now he's talking
about pardoning himself openly he
started tweeting things like this mark
Penn why are there people well here's
this will do this one okay
as has been stated by numerous legal
scholars I have the absolute right to
pardon myself but why would I do that
when I have done nothing wrong in the
meantime the never ending witch hunt led
by 13 very angry and conflicted
Democrats capital a capital key C
capital D and others continues into the
midterms so the reason he's bring up
pardoning himself is because Rudy
Giuliani brought up the idea of Trump
pardoning himself here's what he had to
say
he propped his not but he probably does
he has no intention of pardoning himself
but he probably doesn't say you can't I
mean that is another entry really
interesting constitutional argument can
the president part themselves run the
pardon attorney it would be an open
question I think it would probably get
answered by gosh that's what the
Constitution says and if you want to
change it change it but yeah okay so the
assumption of the Constitution is
probably the president could part
himself me to get impeached if the
president committed a crime worthy of
pardoning himself he would probably be
impeached but in any case bringing this
sort of thing up is not particularly
helpful when you're trying not to look
guilty it's probably not good to even be
discussing this like Giuliani's answer
should have been it when asked could the
president pardon himself his actual
answer should have been why are you even
asking me this he's not guilty of
anything so why would you possibly want
to pardon himself right that's the
proper answer instead you have both
Giuliani and the president talking about
pardoning himself it's just bad politics
and then apparently Giuliani told
HuffPost on Sunday quote in no case can
he be subpoenaed or indicted the
President of the United States I don't
know how you can indict while he's in
office no matter what it is so in any
case so the president is apparently
above law he says if he shot James Comey
he'd be impeached the next day impeach
him and then he can
do whatever you want to him that is not
correct okay so the president could be
brought up on state murder charges if
you were to shoot James Comey but this
is one of the really weird things about
the Obama the Obama versus the Trump
administration so there are a lot of
people who believe that the Trump
administration is broadening the expanse
of presidential powers that President
Trump has widened the the number of
powers available to the office and
deepened the powers already available to
the office of the executive and because
he mouths off about it a lot the reality
is that Trump really has not he really
has not expanded the power of the
executive in any major way in fact most
everything that he is doing has been a
revision of powers that Obama already
grabbed or he has tossed in the
legislature he's actually revising
regulations that Obama put in place in
the first place he has almost a
precisely opposite tactic to President
Obama when it comes to presidential
power so Obama would go out there and
say I'm not changing anything there's no
nothing we don't have a power do that we
don't wait 22 times President Obama says
we're not the power to unilaterally
suspend operation law we can't be wet
that's crazy
we never do that and then of course he
goes ahead and does it right so
President Obama had a nasty habit but
saying he was not expanding presidential
power while expanding presidential power
president Trump has a nasty habit of
saying that he can expand presidential
power and then not expanding
presidential power the best of all
worlds would be to say no I don't want
to expand presidential power and no it
oughtn't be expanded and we're not going
to expand it and I'm gonna kick more
stuff over to the legislature that's
what everybody should be doing but
nobody's actually going to do that which
is really sort of silly Trump is not
going to have to pardon himself because
he's not gonna be brought up on charges
is the reality and president Trump
fulminating over this stuff just makes
it this is my opinion
president Trump should stop fulminating
over this stuff he should let the
investigation go forward everybody who
believes the investigation as corrupt
already believes the investigation is
corrupt now the the only case to be made
in favor of the tweets is that I guess
it distracts from everything else he's
doing and the media are chasing
president Trump around and his comments
on his stuff like a cat following the
laser pointer but I'm just not sure that
when President Trump tweets about
stormtrooper tactics it's particularly
useful here's what President from
tweeted yesterday quote Mark Penn why
are there people from the Clinton
Foundation on the Moller staff why is
there an independent counsel to go after
people and their families for unrelated
offenses Constitution was set up to
prevent this stormtrooper tactics almost
a disgrace
okay no actually this is not a
stormtrooper tactic okay stormtroopers
like stormtroopers were people who
literally busted down doors illegally in
the middle of the night without any
warrant whatsoever and no legal basis
for their action that's not the same
thing as setting up an independent
counsel who was set up I should mention
it by a trump pup pointy I should as you
just point that out a little bit and
that Trump can fire at any time again
does any of this have any real impact I
don't think any of this has a real
impact on president Trump but it does
lend an air of chaos to the
administration that is not useful when
the president is should be busily
pursuing better policy okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like so
today I'm going to discuss ad nauseam
solo so if you've not seen solo yet
you're probably not going to because
it's not doing very well at the box
office which is too bad because I
actually really like this movie I
thought this movie was was fun I thought
it had nothing to do with Han Solo kind
of it had a lot of references to Han
Solo is sort of a giant reference to Han
Solo here's a little bit of the preview
in case you missed it you're off to
something
[Music]
is it revenge
money
[Music]
or is it something else
little rough around the edges but good
heard about a job big shot gangster
putting together crews okay so here my
thoughts on this on this film so let's
start off with the 30,000 foot thoughts
on this film and where it fits in the
Star Wars Canon and universe so let's
start off with the fact that the force
awakens in the last Jedi are hot flaming
garbage okay they are flaming garbage I
said this after the force awakens came
out they murdered my childhood because
han Solo was the coolest character in
the original series and then they killed
him for no reason at all they brought
him back just akela because Harrison
Ford said he want to be killed off so
stupid so dumb if you're gonna do
nostalgia play what you do is you have
everybody have kids and then you have
everybody retire off into the distance
and that's it okay what you don't do is
kill off beloved characters by making
them divorced lose her father's we're
flying around and there's 67 Durango you
know and then they come back just to get
murdered by their child like that's so
dumb han Solo was the coolest guy in the
galaxy and you turned him into the guy
who abandoned his kid when his kid was
like 11 and then he runs around being an
idiot like it's just it's so stupid yeah
the floor so we can still makes me angry
so I gotten over that anger and then I
saw Solo and the reason that I got angry
after seeing Solo is because once again
you cannot kill off a key character and
then make three prequels about him which
was supposed to be the idea here is this
was gonna be a trilogy okay you don't
kill off a beloved character for many of
us who grew up on these movies and then
say let me tell you the backstory of the
character we just killed off in the
stupidest possible way that's just
idiotic beyond that they recast Han Solo
right they cast him as alden ehrenreich
which is fine i'll Xander like I thought
too did a just I think is very good
actor by the way if he's even hail
Caeser he's really versatile he does a
lot of good things and Donald Glover as
Lando works perfectly all this is good
there there's a bunch of good things
about this movie that are call-outs and
I'm not a big fan of the newly the newly
minted importance of the dice that are
on the Millennium Falcon I mean now it's
like every other shot in this movie is
the shot of the dice to reunite it with
the importance of the force awakens in
the last Jedi which is just dumb okay it
was never important in the original
movies I didn't know there were dice on
the Millennium Falcon until I saw force
awakens and people made a big deal out
of it okay like really I didn't even
realize they were dice up there it was
supposed to be like a little joke I
guess but in any case I'm in any case
there to to if they're gonna recast Han
Solo I guess the objection was that we
couldn't recast Harrison Ford and
Markham
and Carrie Fisher because there were two
iconic and so if we're gonna do movies
after Return of the Jedi then those
movies had to fast forward to the
current age where the actors are and
then we have to work within that
framework but if you're gonna recast Han
Solo as Alden Ehrenreich why didn't you
for example just recast Donald Glover as
Lando Alden Ehrenreich as han Solo I
just recast Mark Hamill everybody will
get it right be like James Bond okay so
it's just new person who's coming in
who's playing these characters for a new
generation that's fine it would been
okay people would had a hard time with
it at the beginning I probably would
have moaned about it a little bit and
then if the movie been really good it
would been good instead you get the
whole expanded universe of force awakens
and last Jedi which are just terrible
because again you're fast-forwarding 30
years the rebellion is still the
rebellion for some odd reason and
everybody's turned into a loser
Luke's off on a planet being a loser
somewhere and he never had kids they
never did anything useful and you've got
Rey who no one cares about he got Finn
who no one cares about he got Poe who no
one cares about and he got Han Solo
getting killed like a loser Luke like
astral projecting himself and then dying
out of exhaustion which is just
ridiculous and then you got Carrie
Fisher who actually is dead now and
you're stuck because she's dead right in
real life so what they could have done
and I think this would've been so much
better because I've talked up the Star
Wars books before I've talked up the
novels that we used to be part of the
Canon after Star Wars after the Death
Star is destroyed in Return of the Jedi
there is still an entire empire out
there it's not like the entire Empire
was on the Death Star
I did a story the first the first Death
Star in the entire empire was still
around in the books there's a guy named
Admiral Thrawn who comes along and he
starts to reconstitute the Empire then
you could've had a continuation the
universe could recast everybody and you
could have just continued from there and
it would have been really cool and
really interesting in the books Leia
ends up having twins with Han the twin
there's this whole thing lore where the
twins have the force or not Luke ends up
getting married like there's a lot more
stuff that happens in that series then
basically them just hanging out and
being losers for thirty years which is
what happens beginning with the force
awakens so the point is if you're you
could go one of two directions either
you can recast everybody or you could
fast-forward 60 years and then just
don't pay attention to the old
characters because killing them off one
by one is a real attempt to destroy it
to use a nostalgia to destroy my
childhood and I really object to it okay
so that is objection number one
objection to solo the movie is that the
Alden Ehrenreich character really
doesn't have much to do with Han Solo so
he has his backstory I don't think
han Solo needed a backstory I think
they're adding this in an attempt to to
add to the backstory
the problem with Han Solo's character in
this film is that I think what they're
trying to do and maybe they were they
were gonna get there with the trilogy
that may never happen now they're trying
to show how an optimistic sprightly
young lad kind of a Luke Skywalker
figure ends up like Han Solo so it's not
that Han is naturally cynical
it's that Han used to be really ideal
idealistic and all this sort of stuff
and then on and then Han became cynical
but this movie doesn't show how he'd
become cynical this movie just has him
still being idealistic like he and Luke
Skywalker are much more similar than the
alden ehrenreich han Solo and the and
the Han Solo Han Solo that we've come to
know and love Lando is played exactly
right like Donald Glover gets that on
the nose the script writing for Han is
little flawed there are some things
about that movie that I love I mean the
way that they have han and chewie meat
is really great like that really works
and it's really funny and it's really
good
I think Woody Harrelson does a good job
in the film there's a whole weird kind
of sjw side plot with robot rights that
I'm not sure if they were supposed to be
playing for laughs or whether they were
supposed to be playing it seriously but
I don't really have a problem with them
with the movie in fact one things I
liked about the movie is that finally
they actually cast a human being as the
bad guy right Paul Bettany plays the bad
guy and he's actually a human he's not
like a weird-looking creeper so that's
kind of easily just a human looking
creeper so that's kind of that's kind of
good um Emilia Clarke can't act her way
out of a paper bag which is unfortunate
but if you've ever watched Game of
Thrones you know this which is one of
the reasons that that Daenerys Targaryen
can never end up on the full on the on
the throne at the end of Game of Thrones
if she does it's a complete
disappointment but in any case what they
really needed to do with the in the end
of this movie so spoiler alerts now I
really haven't spoiled a lot yet spoiler
alert now okay the the real what what
they should have done at the end of the
movie is they should have had the
rebellion right the people who are
working with the rebellion accidentally
kill Han Solo's love interest and then
you could see why he's so cynical about
the rebellion and also why he's cynical
about love right that would have done it
but maybe there maybe that's their plan
in future movies but I'm not sure
they're gonna do future movies because
this movie is gonna lose hand over fist
at the box office until they ended up
clearing about 400 million dollars which
sounds like 500 million dollars maybe
with quote with foreign returns that
means that it doesn't break even because
they spent several hundred million
dollars on the making of the film on the
marketing of the film it's hard to see
what
they go from here kathleen kennedy has
done a terrible job steering the Star
Wars universe rogue one was a very good
movie so was a pretty good movie and the
fact that they did what they did with
force awakens in the last Jedi is
impossible to get over it's impossible
because now either have to make a
nostalgia play for characters you killed
off in the worst possible way or you
have to make spin-offs about characters
you don't care about like Poe Dameron
and Finn right like what they really
should have done again but they should
have done is they should have instead of
relaunching if they're gonna do a Marvel
style instead of relaunching with force
awakens in last Jedi
they should have relaunched with rogue
one and solo and then they should have
moved forward from after Return of the
Jedi or fast forward in 60 years when
everybody's already presumed dead
basically and then moved on into the new
Star Wars universe instead they decided
to capitalize on the assault Joe as a
short-sighted play and it has some
really negative ramifications for this
movie which i think is quite good I
think that you know I've been kind of
arguing whether this is better than
Revenge of the Sith I think it's better
than Revenge of the Sith on second
thought so my current Star Wars rankings
are in order Empire Strikes Back episode
4 rogue 1 return to the Jedi solo
Revenge of the Sith everything else is
hot garbage that's that's the those are
the official Star Wars rankings here on
the bench Shapiro's show and anyone who
disagrees will be summarily fired
alright time for a couple of things that
I hate already so Milania she's not
missing so a lot of people making this
argument like how crazy are people right
now so you remember during the last
election cycle when people said maybe
Hillary has some health problems and
everybody was like no you can't say
Hillary has health problems
she's the healthiest woman who ever
lived Hillary Clinton that woman could
compete in a triathlon tomorrow with one
arm disconnected from her body she can
do one-arm pull-ups Hillary Clinton that
woman can jump tall buildings in a
single bound she's faster than a
speeding bullet then she like fell down
in the middle of a 9/11 memorial and she
like had to be dragged into a van you
remember them they like threw her into a
van like a sack of potatoes and drove
home remember this okay so everybody was
considered conspiratorial person who's
worried about her health hey now you
have mainstream media figures or
legitimately wondering where could
Melania Trump be why because she had a
kidney surgery like three weeks ago and
she hasn't been seen publicly maybe guys
it's because she had a kidney surgery
three weeks ago maybe it's that so the
going
Yuriy was that Donald Trump like punch
Melania in the face and she'd want to
appear all she had a black eye or some
such nonsense okay this is the stupidest
baby the world it's so dumb
first of all I'm not convinced that
Donald Trump in Milan you ever see each
other
second of all like what do you have to
go on here except for Donald Trump is
bad so people were tweeting out like I
wouldn't even had to think about this
except that Donald Trump is president
really okay so maybe Melania was
abducted by aliens you wouldn't even had
to think about that but now Donald Trump
is president so anything's possible so
brian Stelter did an entire segment on
this on CNN reliable sources did a
segment and where is Melania Trump it's
like Where's Waldo
except for Slovenian fashion models yeah
and then and then there there are a
couple of tweets that went out about so
Melania tweeted out about those Melania
finally was forced to tweet out I see
the media is working overtime
speculating where I am and what I'm
doing rest assured I'm here at the White
House with my family feeling great and
working hard on behalf of children and
the American people this of course led
everybody on the left to say it was
faked it's like the moon landing she's
actually dead somewhere in the basement
she's actually there they're wheeling
around like weekend at Bernie's who's
actually trump who went in and hacked
into her account and started tweeting
from her accounts so stay and then Jim
Carrey who's completely lost whatever
was left to his mind tweeted out this
bizarre picture I don't know why Jim
Carrey thinks that he's good at painting
but no he tweeted out a picture of
Melania Trump being like rien doctrine
ated Clockwork Orange style says don't
worry folks Melania is fine they're
probably just reminding her how to play
well with others
I know what happened to Jim Carrey or
whether it was always like this but um
folks on the left you don't get to claim
that everybody on the rights of
conspiracy theorist while you're
claiming stuff like this so that is a
thing that I hate today okay final thing
I hate will do a federalist paper
tomorrow because we're sort of at a time
but we'll do a final thing I hate you
know people say we should trust the FBI
and I'm inclined to believe there are a
lot of good FBI agents and then I see
videos like this and I think wow that's
not great so here's an FBI agent who was
dancing at a party you'll see him do a
backflip
drop his gun and try to pick it up and
shoot somebody this is video of a man at
a Denver nightclub cutting loose on the
dance floor but something else is loose
too as he flips his handgun flies out of
its holster to the floor then
accidentally going off as he picks it up
watch again as he reaches there
that muzzle flash the bullet striking a
man in the crowd okay the guy was fine
yeah he was hit by the bullet
but um yeah when people say trust the
FBI um yeah yeah that's not the best
argument guys you might want to like
take care of your agents a little better
also like who does backflips while
carrying a gun in there in the back of
there of the like I'll be honest I'm not
somebody who conceals and carries
because it's illegal in the state of
California but I'll get a lot of emails
I need I need emails from people you
know about like whether if you're
concealing and carrying do you put the
gun in the back while you're doing these
weird moves do a back flip so that it
falls out of your pants like wouldn't
you be afraid that you'd shoot yourself
in the ass just just a question but
maybe I'm wrong okay so good exploits
from the FBI well done FBI once again
really doing yeoman's work okay we'll be
back here tomorrow to discuss all of the
latest news plus we'll do a little bit
of Federalist paper ink it up i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018